Durante casi 25 años, el sistema de protección de datos en Chile se ha guiado por una normativa
que, seamos sinceros, actuaba como un tigre de papel, la antigua Ley 19.628.
Pero bueno, el escenario acaba de dar un vuelco radical.
En el análisis de hoy, vamos a desgranar a fondo este nuevo paradigma de privacidad
y la Ley 21.719.
Hablamos de una reforma monumental, un cambio de las reglas del juego que alinea por fin
al país con el exigente estándar europeo del GDPR.
Para que no nos perdamos, nuestra hoja de ruta de hoy tiene cinco paradas rápidas.
Primero, le diremos adiós a la vieja Ley 19.628.
Segundo, repasaremos los nuevos derechos ARSOP.
Tercero, conoceremos a la nueva autoridad reguladora.
Cuarto, hablaremos de plazos y de cómo afecta esto a las pymes.
Y quinto, marcaremos los pasos clave para la adecuación.
Empezamos con el primer bloque, el adiós definitivo a la Ley 19.628 y la enorme transición
legal desde 1999.
Hasta 2024.
Fíjate bien, porque no estamos ante un simple lavado de cara o un parche normativo.
Es una reconstrucción estructural de arriba a abajo.
El viejo modelo de 1999 era, digamos, demasiado relajado.
Se basaba en el consentimiento tácito, no había una autoridad real que vigilara y las
multas eran tan pero tan irrisorias que a muchas empresas literalmente les salía más
a cuenta infringir la ley que cumplirla.
El nuevo horizonte de 2026 cambia esto por completo.
Ahora se exige una alineación internacional, el consentimiento tiene que ser totalmente
explícito y, ojo a esto, introduce el concepto de responsabilidad proactiva.
O sea, ya no vale con reaccionar, hay que prevenir.
Pasamos al segundo punto, los nuevos derechos ARSOP.
Y cómo esta ley busca empoderar de verdad al ciudadano.
El objetivo principal aquí es devolverle a cada persona el control absoluto sobre su
huella digital.
Históricamente, siempre nos hemos centrado en los famosos derechos ARCO, ya sabes, acceso
rectificación, cancelación y oposición.
Pues bien, la nueva ley añade un par de piezas clave y transforma el acrónimo en ARSOP.
Añade la portabilidad, que básicamente te permite exigir que tu información se transfiera
directamente a otro proveedor.
Y además suma el bloqueo temporal, que es una herramienta potentísima para congelar
el procesamiento de tus datos si hay algún tipo de disputa abierta.
Y hay un número que debes grabarte a fuego.
30.
30 días hábiles.
Ese es el plazo máximo legal, inamovible, que tiene cualquier organización.
Para responder a una solicitud ARSOP.
Se acabó eso de darle largas al usuario con burocracia interminable.
Ahora, retrasarse es abrirle la puerta de par en par a sanciones muy, muy severas.
Vamos con el tercer bloque.
Toca conocer a la APDP, el nuevo supervisor que, esta vez sí, viene con dientes.
Porque claro, al final del día, los derechos son simples sugerencias si no hay nadie que
obligue a cumplirlos.
La Agencia de Protección de Datos Personales, o APDP, no es un mero panel consultorio.
Es un cultivo que da consejos, que va.
Es una corporación pública totalmente autónoma.
Tiene el poder exclusivo para interpretar la ley, auditar oficinas, exigir documentación
confidencial y, lo más importante, dictar resoluciones inmediatas que, literalmente,
podrían paralizar las operaciones de cualquier empresa de un día para otro.
Para entender de verdad el peso de esta nueva agencia, hablemos de dinero.
Las multas tienen un tope de 20.000 UTM.
Para que te hagas una idea, al cambio, estamos hablando de unos 14 millones de pesos chilenos.
Es una barbaridad.
Un riesgo financiero tan monumental que coloca la privacidad exactamente al mismo nivel de
importancia que los impuestos o las leyes laborales dentro de cualquier consejo de administración.
A ver, estas multas operan bajo una estructura de pirámide.
Todo empieza con infracciones leves de hasta 5.000 UTM, por típicos errores administrativos
menores.
El escalón grave sube a 10.000 UTM, por cosas como, por ejemplo, ignorar los derechos
a IRESOP que mencionábamos antes.
Y, finalmente, el nivel gravísimo, que castiga con esas 20.000 UTM conductas críticas como
tratar los dos sensibles de forma ilegal.
Punto crucial aquí.
Si una empresa es reincidente, la multa ya no es una cantidad fisa, sino que puede calcularse
sobre un porcentaje de sus ingresos anuales a nivel global.
Poca broma con esto.
Cuarto punto de nuestra agenda.
Plazos y al régimen especial para pymes.
Básicamente, la cuenta regresiva hacia 2026.
El reloj ya está haciendo tic-tac.
Todo esto arrancó en diciembre de 2024, cuando se publicó la ley, abriendo un periodo de
adaptación de 24 meses.
Pero, ojo, esta ventana se cierra de golpe el 1 de diciembre de 2026.
Esa es la fecha crítica.
A partir de ese día, la PDP asume plenos poderes y el rigor de las multas entra en vigor al
100%.
Sin embargo, la ley tiene un toque de pragmatismo económico.
Para no ahogar el emprendimiento de buenas a primeras, hay un régimen transitorio para
las pymes.
Las micro y pequeñas empresas van a tener 12 meses extra.
Es decir, hasta diciembre de 2027 estarán bajo un modelo puramente correctivo.
Si incumplen algo, recibirán una amonestación oficial para que lo arreglen, pero sin la
multa económica de por medio.
Ojo, es un respiro vital para adaptarse.
Sí, pero en ningún caso significa que estén exentas de cumplir la ley.
Y llegamos a la recta final.
Sección 5.
La hoja de ruta de adecuación y los pasos exactos para el cumplimiento corporativo.
Este es el manual de acción que toda empresa necesita para alinear su tecnología, sus
recursos humanos y sus prácticas legales.
El paso 1 es hacer un diagnóstico sincero y elaborar el registro de actividades de tratamiento
o RAT.
Al final, no puedes proteger lo que no sabes que tienes, ¿verdad?
El paso 2 es auditar el argumento legal.
El paso 3 obliga a reescribir las políticas de privacidad y despedirse para siempre del
viejo truco de las casillas premarcadas para obtener el consentimiento.
Y por último, el paso 4 que exige hacer evaluaciones de impacto obligatorias antes de meterse con
tecnologías de alto riesgo, como usar inteligencia artificial para tomar decisiones automatizadas.
Y aquí es vital desmontar uno de los grandes mitos sobre la privacidad.
Conseguir el consentimiento explícito de la persona no es la única vía para usar sus
datos.
La ley establece hasta seis bases legales.
Aparte del consentimiento, puedes tratar datos si son necesarios para ejecutar un contrato,
para cumplir una obligación legal, para proteger un interés vital en una emergencia, por temas
de interés público o bajo el paraguas del interés legítimo de la organización.
Basar toda tu estrategia únicamente en pedir permiso es un error estratégico que debilita
muchísimo la operativa diaria.
Todo este inmenso esfuerzo de adaptación converge en algo llamado Modelo de Prevención
de Infracciones, o MPI.
A ver, es un programa de cumplimiento totalmente voluntario, pero desde un punto de vista estratégico,
es oro puro.
Si lo implementas y logras que la agencia lo certifique, te estás construyendo un escuro
defensivo increíble.
Es demostrar máxima diligencia.
Si algún día sufres un ciberataque, una brecha de seguridad, tener un MPI certificado
actúa como un atenuante clave que reduce drásticamente tu exposición legal y, sobre
todo, financiera.
Así que, con un marco normativo completamente rediseñado, ciudadanos mucho más conscientes
de sus derechos y una agencia reguladora lista para morder, solo queda una gran parte de
la pregunta en el aire.
¿Está tu organización realmente preparada para abrir sus puertas al escrutinio legal
el 1 de diciembre de 2026?
El periodo de mentalizarse y tomar conciencia ya pasó.
Ahora es el momento de remangarse y ejecutar.
Esperemos que este repaso sirva como ese empujón definitivo para pasar a la acción.